la première qui se trouve tout le monde
se pose la question pourquoi frédéric
lopez n'est pas parti avec vous
il a décidé d'arrêter parce que c'était
vous l'invitez où il avait décidé vrai
nom mais bah écoutes je crois qu'il
s'est exprimé là-dessus frais d'un mois
pour se dire la vérité j'ai eu
évidemment du mal à comprendre
et puis quand j'ai pour te dire ça a
commencé quand on a fait les adieux et
je me suis rendu compte que c'était
extrêmement difficile de vivre avec des
gens de s'attacher à eux et de partir en
sachant qu'on les reverra jamais de
notre vie fred il a vécu sa 25 fois et
juste après ça on n'a jamais vu juste
après m'avoir dit je pars pas et il m'a
pris dans un coin en me disant tu vas
vivre le voyage de ta vie moi j'en avais
fait 25 des comme ça et si je continue
je vais devenir fou et j'ai compris
quand je suis parti là-bas de quoi il
parlait parce que sincèrement c'est une
expérience incroyable en fait à frère
fred lopez
ça lui faisait beaucoup de bien ça
faisait beaucoup de nos invités mais à
la fin ça lui faisait du mal toute cette
émotion
ouais en fait il s'est attaché à des
gens et puis après comme les revoyait
plus et fred il a craqué porté par les
lilas et franchement c'est voilà moi
j'aime beaucoup ce garçon ce qui est
très sensible un fred strychnine
sensibilité un problème est donc pour
lui de ces tests et roux alors oui
complètement
oui et c'est juste quelques semaines
avant de partir avec franck qu'il a
présenté son successeur à la chaîne et
que la chaîne a accepté c'est vrai donc
il a su qu'il y avait un successeur à ce
moment là votre voyage avec lui c'est
confirmé et il stressait j'ai eu la
production aujourd'hui istres et c'est
énormément en se disant c'est franck on
ne s'est pas totalement comment il va
réagir
il avait préparé plusieurs scénarios et
le scénario le pire pour eux c'était que
vous disiez puisque c'est ça je ne parle
pas il avait anticipé ça mais il misait
sur sa force de conviction pour vous
dire allez-y alors froch
vous avez participé donc comme j'ai dit
aux tâches et aux coutumes locales
le dépaysement est total pour vous et
moi j'aime bien parce que franck même
quand il galère il veut aller au bout de
craie
oui c'est pas le bon arbre ah bon si tu
sais pas travailler ce n'est pas la
peine de venir
santos a way qui a fait 1 2 n'arrive pas
à faire des pompes ans et pourtant c'est
un travail facile tu va pas assez vite
laisse moi faire avec la technique de
franck je crois que malheureusement on
n'aura pas de beurre aujourd'hui prendre
la terre il faut frotter très forte
tu l'as pas bien fait c'est encore salle
de danse au moins tu essaies
est ce que ces genres d'émissions que tu
tu regardes encore à la télé j'ai pas
regardé celle là c'est je vais jouer la
gagne quoi si j'étais fracassé mon ami
hier soir suis sorti tard de la radio et
mais je vais la voir parce que tu sais
que je t'aime bien et j'ai envie de la
voir et je trouve que c'est une belle
émission et je pense qu'à faire j'ai une
question
question de téléspectateurs quand la
dame vous parle dans une autre langue
il ya quelqu'un qui traduit et que parce
que c'est très bien fait on envoie moi
c'est vrai que jamais le traducteur
donc il dit elle a dit ceci tu répond eh
ouais en fait le temps de traduction et
effacé du montage où tu vois pas parce
qu'en fait mais moi je moi je croyais et
je suis sûr que c'est une question tout
est une bonne question qu'aurait parce
que moi je croyais que les maîtres
parler toutes les langues qu il a crevé
matin d'un coup de sabot comme tu peux
c'est fou ouais et puis alors ce qui est
fou le plus incroyable dans cette
histoire c'est qu'évidemment pendant
toutes ces discussions il ya un mec qui
parle français et en l'occurrence
indiens et qui fait les traductions
simultanées ont continué à se regarder
toujours dans les yeux oui un truc dont
fred m'avait parlé très tôt serre que
pendant 17 jours on se regarde dans les
yeux des heures et des heures chaque
jour
ça crée un truc très très fort et il ya
un moment où on n'a plus trop besoin de
traducteur parce qu'il ya des moments où
on part se balader avec eux et ont fini
par réussir à ce qu'on s'a à se
comprendre il faut alors vous allez me
dire si vous zappez aussi vous matez
autour de la table et chez vous aussi si
vous avez matteo si vous avez zappé pour
vous rendre sur le lieu de tournage il a
fallu quatre jours et au style du voyage
on voit que vous rigolez voilà les miens
mais c'est vrai que le voyage est
éprouvant et mine de rien tu lâches pas
tu veux pas lâcher d'un moment tu t'es
pas dire je vais je chante peluche au
bout du rouleau
non parce que tu n'attends que ça de
rencontrer ces gens c'est vrai que c'est
là le vrai but de ce voyage c'est de
rencontrer des gens une autre culture
quelque chose tu as ta conscience que tu
m'as vis quelque chose d'incroyable donc
et puis tu sais le voyage fait partie de
cette avancée incroyable je me rappelle
qu'on a on le voit pas dans le film on a
traversées des villages qui étaient
tellement éloigné de tout cas chaque
fois je me disais mais ça doit être cet
endroit là c'est pas possible il n'ya
pas un autre village encore plus haut et
bas 6 et puis si et puis écoute je peux
vous raconter mille choses qui sont pas
dans le film parce qu'on a tourné deux
cent cinquante heures il me fait deux
heures non mais
à un moment on a marché deux jours pour
aller dans un petit village et on a dû
s'arrêter parce qu'il restait encore
trop de route et j'ai dit à une dame
mais comment vous faites quand vous êtes
malade et elle m'a dit quand on est
vraiment malade on n'a pas le temps de
descendre on meurt avant juste pour te
dire isolement dans laquelle ils vivent
c'est quoi ouais c'est assez fort alors
regarde ton voyage
on va prendre un peu de temps pour y
aller ouais on a encore quatre jours de
voyage avoir des rencontres et là
l'objectif ça serait d'arriver avant 22
heures ça sonne bien et vite
la période
merci d'être venus justice on a combien
de temps de marche pour arriver là où w
il faut environ quatre heures pour
monter
d'accord
[Musique]
on sent quand même les effets de
l'altitude
[Musique]
ma future maman a vraiment l'air de
souffrir parce que tu pleures de la tête
[Applaudissements]